لا يزال ممول مرتبط بحركة حماس محكوم عليه لمدة
10 سنوات بتهم الفساد في السودان
يحتفظ بشبكة من
المصالح التجارية في أوروبا على الرغم من خضوعه
للعقوبات الأمريكية. عبد الباسط حمزة، رجل
أعمال سوداني مرتبط بالولايات المتحدة بأسامة
بن لادن، تم القبض عليه في عام 2019 في السودان
بعد سقوط نظام الحكم.  الدكتاتور عمر
البشير وسجنته
السلطات السودانية بعد ذلك بسبب تعامله مع
أموال حماس من بين أمور أخرى، لكن
الولايات المتحدة لم تفرض عقوبات على حمزة إلا
بعد هجوم الجماعة المسلحة في 7 أكتوبر
على إسرائيل، وعملنا
بالاشتراك مع منصة التحقيق الإسرائيلية
الشام والاتحاد الدولي
للتحقيقات.  الصحافة
ICI باستخدام الوثائق المقدمة إلى CNN
من تسريب سري لـ Cypress، وهي
مجموعة من أكثر من 3.6 مليون وثيقة
تم تحليلها بواسطة ICI و68 Media Partners،
كشفت الوثائق عن الكثير من
محفظة أعمال حمزة في أوروبا، وهي جزء
من شبكة من الأصول العالمية التي
يقدرها السودانيون سابقًا  مسؤولو مكافحة الفساد تبلغ
ثروتهم أكثر من 2 مليار دولار،
توضح السجلات الورقية أن التعاملات التجارية التي أجراها همهمة
في أوروبا مستمرة لبعض
الوقت على مدى عقدين من الزمن، وهي
تشمل شركة قبرصية، وشركة ذهب مصرية، وشركة
عقارات إسبانية،
وشركة مقرها السد خاضعة لعقوبات من قبل  بعد
أقل من أسبوع من 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
نفى حمزة أي تورط له في
تمويل حماس، وفي رد مكتوب
نفى أيضًا أي علاقة بأسامة بن
لادن، واصفًا نفسه
بالسجين السياسي الذي أطلقت
السلطات السودانية سراحه وهو بريء تمامًا في
يونيو/حزيران
2012، ونفت الحكومة الإسرائيلية ذلك.  لشبكة CNN
أن تصرفاتها في السنوات الأخيرة
عززت موقف هام ماس، وتساءل عما إذا
كان التمويل الذي قدمه حمزة حاسماً
لهجوم 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول.
قال مستشار السياسة الخارجية لنتنياهو لشبكة CNN، حيث
كررنا هذا السؤال
وسيتم فحص العديد من الأسئلة الأخرى بعد الحرب.
أمر مجلس وزراء الحرب
جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي بتدمير حماس وإطلاق
سراح الرهائن. تركز إسرائيل بشكل كامل على
إنجاز تلك المهام.
تم الاتصال بالشريك التجاري الأوروبي لحمزة
للتعليق على العقوبات الأمريكية
ونفى أن يكون لحمزة أي علاقات مع حماس
في نوفمبر، كما فرضت المملكة المتحدة عقوبات على
حمزة ولكن  لم يتم
فرض عقوبات عليه من قبل الاتحاد الأوروبي بعد، لكن
هذه ليست المرة الأولى التي يواجه فيها رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو
مزاعم بأنه قلل من أهمية حماس، مما أدى إلى
عواقب مميتة. وقد ذكرت شبكة سي إن إن وشام
سابقًا كيف
سمح نتنياهو لحماس بتلقي ملايين
الدولارات نقدًا  الحقائب التي قدمتها
قطر لأسباب إنسانية، أثارت
صعوبة مراقبة مثل هذه المبالغ الكبيرة
من النقد مخاوف داخل
حكومة نتنياهو من بين
مسؤولين آخرين. لقد أوقفت الحقائب النقدية
لأنني أعتقد أن
السماح لكاماس بالحصول على كل هذه
الحقائب مليئة بالنقود التي تذهب هو خطأ فادح.
مباشرة لإعادة تسليحهم ضد
الإسرائيليين، لماذا نطعمهم المال
لقتلنا؟ لا تزال شبكات تمويل حماس
قضية مثيرة للجدل بشكل خاص بالنسبة
لإسرائيل. قال الجيش الإسرائيلي يوم الثلاثاء إنه
قتل رجلاً فلسطينياً متهماً
بأنه ممول بارز لحماس
كجزء من عملية لـ  اقتباس: تفكيك
تمويل حماس: هذه
الاكتشافات الجديدة تشعل نار النقاد الذين يقولون
إن إسرائيل
والولايات المتحدة قللت من التهديد الذي
تشكله حماس ولم تفعلا ما يكفي
للحد من شبكتها العالمية غير المشروعة من
المصالح التجارية،
ولم تستجب وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية لطلب سي إن إن
للتعليق على CNN لندن